thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
because you have been a delightful
audience I think I might
open the floor to some requests
number five
foreign
I am quite fond of that one number five
it is may I play with you monsieur
what
may I play along with you
all right fine come up here
oh no who put you up to this
myself miss you
pardon me
do you believe you'll be needing
one of these
it seems I've left mine in the shop
in the shop
Now ladies and gentlemen I give you
music featuring help
from a dark stranger
I assume you know this piece
yes
well I hope this won't be embarrassing
for you
from the Allegro
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
to my Cadenza
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
he's that
[Music]